Welcome back everyone
Happy New Year
A lot of you been asking me
if Marvel is going to recast Jonathan Majors Kang
All the Kang variants he was going to play,
he was going to basically play all the main versions
that they'd be fighting during Avengers
five, in a bunch of sites.
This week, we're reporting
that they actually found a replacement actor.
As a result, they're changing Avengers
five story in now, a lot of you have also asked
if they're going through this much trouble
to recast such a major character like Kang,
all the Kang variants,
why didn't they recast Black Panther, for example,
if he was so important to them on a story level,
I'd argue they had even bigger plans for Black Panther
than they did for Kang.
they were going to make him the new center of the MCU.
Like everything going forward
was going to revolve around him.
thankfully, Marvel has actually been pretty public
with why they made certain decisions.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
It's a developing situation,
especially with all the Kang stuff.
but probably the biggest news you've all been seeing
in your feeds since New Year's this week is that Colman
Domingo is supposedly Marvel's top pick to replace
Jonathan Majors is all the different Kang variants.
If they're going with him, I think he's a solid choice.
He's a great actor.
Most of you will either remember him from Fear
The Walking Dead, because he was on that
for a number of years, and he was just the voice
of the new Unicron in Transformers Rise of the Beasts
presumably he'll continue to play Unicron in future
Transformers movies
if he becomes kang because it's a voiceover role.
So there's no big conflict in what a coincidence.
A while ago he actually talked about joining Marvel
specifically as a villain, I'm jumping it?
It's it's funny, just the other day
I was looking at something.
I thought, like, that's wow,
I haven't been a part of any.
I'm I'm part of the fear.
The Walking Dead universe,
what comes in the marvel of DC.
I'm like, I think I'm ready now.
It worked out that I think want to play a villain.
I just wanted to be the villain.
I don't want to be the good guy.
I actually want to do some really nasty, dirty work,
so I want her to call me for a villain.
That's it.
that interview was taken
before all the drama with Jonathan Majors went down.
So I don't think he was talking to Marvel
about kang specifically when that was happening.
but he might have had meetings with Marvel
about other villains that he wanted to play,
and that's why he was referencing that.
And then the business with Jonathan Majors
goes down earlier this year.
Marvel still needs to wrap up
their counsel of Kang storyline somehow.
It's such a big part of Avengers five and here, Colman
Domingo is ready to go,
waiting to get called up from the dugout.
And things just happened to work out for him that way.
let me know in the comments
if Marvel is going to recast Kang, even if it's only
to wrap up his storyline in Avengers five,
who do you want to play that character?
there to establish that variance.
Don't
all have to look the same way back in Loki Season one.
Like you have people that look vastly different.
Sylvie is probably the best example that she is.
Another Loki that just happens to be a woman
looks completely different from Tom Hiddleston.
no. I know it's
none of you are asking if they're doing that for Kang.
Why aren't they recasting Black Panther?
I'll get to that in a second.
Marvel's been more open about why they did
what they did with the Black Panther character.
but they're still changing Avengers five story
regardless of what they do with the actual Kang
character.
And it's all about getting past the whole Kang
storyline just in general.
Originally it sounded like Marvel's
plan was to actually pull a Naruto.
basically they were going to copy
some of the tropes of the series
with their villains in their last couple of arcs.
if you did watch that series or you read the manga
specifically the Fourth Shinobi War,
there was all kinds of backstabbing, lesser villains
who were hyped up to be big bads.
But then in comes a much bigger villain,
killing the lesser villain
to show
how they were so much more powerful and dangerous.
The heroes have absolutely no hope so
if you hear people joking about how Marvel is pulling
a Naruto with Avengers five in the Council of Kangs ,
that's what they're talking about.
it's been posted many times before.
But you see people using this Rick
and Morty meme to basically explain the progression
of all the different villains.
You have to imagine Marvel
doing this with the Council of Kangs.
Basically,
you end with like one major villain
killing all the lesser
villains in that way there being some greater villain,
killing the Council of Kangs.
Marvel's version of this would have involved
the Council of Kangs coming for the new main 616
Avengers in the main universe.
they wind up fighting the three main variants
that are at the head of the council
we saw in the Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania
Post-Credits scene Immortus, Scarlet Centurion,
the drama version of Kang Marvel winds up
pulling in Avengers Infinity War and Avengers
Endgame with them, where they basically divide
the Avengers into a couple of different teams
this time three different teams
for the three different variants like Infinity War.
You have one team fighting Thanos on Titan, the other
fighting the black order in Wakanda
ultimately the New Avengers collectively lose
like they get their asses handed to them.
But in comes a more powerful villain.
Naruto style who kills the Council of Kings.
And then you lead directly into Avengers six secret
wars, them collapsing the rest of the multiverse.
kind of like a bigger multiverse
version of the Avengers Infinity War ending work.
Thanos snapped the Infinity Gantlet.
you basically wind up with all the heroes waking up,
but they're all in battle world, and most of them
from the main universe died.
They're just a bunch of survivors from other universes,
like the X-Men universe,
with Hugh Jackman's Wolverine still being there.
Tobey Maguire, Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man universes
with them being on Battle World
here's where we get to the big changes
It sounds like Marvel is making behind the scenes
with the story just overall.
Originally, Avengers
five was called Avengers Kang Dynasty.
In the MCU, the Council of Kangs is canonically called
The Dynasty of Kings.
basically the Council of Kangs fighting the Avengers.
reportedly now since they're recasting Jonathan Majors,
they've taken the Kang Dynasty
off the title of Avengers 5
and they're just referring to it as Avengers 5.
they might change to some other title for the movie.
Marvel trademarked a bunch of movie titles
as placeholders a long time ago
like Avengers Eternity War.
They have infinite options that they can pick from
Either way, Avengers five they wrap up the Kang
storyline in a bigger villain comes along
that's totally different and destroys all of them.
now there's a question
about who that bigger villain is going to be.
There's a lot of different arguments
about who would be a better pick.
Variety reported earlier this year at Marvel's
annual Story
retreat, where Kevin Feige, the other Marvel brass,
decide the future of all the movies and the TV shows
that Marvel discussed, pivoting to Doctor
Doom is a character like we joke
about the great Marvel pivot
I've talked about him in the MCU in past videos.
There are a couple of things they have to do before
they can use him as a big Avengers level character,
namely, develop him in a couple other movies first,
but they could use him.
They still have a little time
to work him into a couple of movies, even if they delay
Avengers 5 to 2027, which it seems like they might now
like even more delays for that.
the other really obvious option
most of you've also thought about this is
they could just use the beyond or character.
if we know that they're going to do secret wars
the Beyond in the Beyond
race are huge parts of both versions of Secret wars
is just as easy to use him,
even if they change the character for example,
before all the Jonathan Majors drama originally
there had been reports that they were going to make
the beyond or the main villain Secret Wars,
but he was going to be another
Kang variant played by Jonathan Majors
that was just calling himself the Beyond or like that
original version that you thought died during Ant-Man.
The Wasp Quantumania would come back
they were going to make the movie
a little bit closer to what they did
with Thanos in Avengers Infinity War.
In Avengers Endgame, were, the same actor
winds up being the villain in both movies.
Kind of just slightly different versions
of the character.
like Final Boss standoff here in Avengers
Endgame wasn't exactly the same as Infinity War.
Thanos He was a younger version
who had slightly different goals.
He was going to wipe all of existence in this universe
and restart from scratch.
Marvel could still use the beyond plan
that they originally had with a recast version of Kang.
Like Don't change the story that much.
Just recast the actor.
But they still have to establish the new Kang variants
like the new actor before Avengers five.
I think it'd be a smoother transition than what
we got with Don Cheadle being recast as Rhodey
after Marvel fired Terrence Howard.
That's the example that everybody points to.
Like, what if they just showed up
at the beginning of Avengers five
and it was a totally different actor in some line
like this?
Like, Yeah, it's me.
I'm here.
Stop asking questions about it.
as easy would be to do that.
We're not talking about like a solo movie here.
Even though Iron Man two was a pretty big movie,
it was still a solo movie.
We're talking about like a huge Avengers level movie.
Everybody on the planet would be going to see this.
so they need to kind of ease people
into that transition.
All they need, though, is like a single post-credits
scene before Avengers five,
whatever That final movie before Avengers
five winds up being you literally
don't have to mention Kang once
until that last post-credits scene.
Then you pick up with someone like Colman Domingo
in Avengers five and it all makes sense.
Then at the end of that movie
you have the Beyond Her or Dr.
Doom Show up and kill everybody on the Council of Kangs
and end on a cliffhanger creating Battle World.
They're supposed to be setting up the whole concept
of battle world during Deadpool three.
and there have been reports about them just expanding
the secret war story and doing it as a two part movie.
So The Avengers five becomes more like Secret Wars.
the funny thing about that too,
is that they just had the what If season two finale.
The finale was kind of like a soft test run
for what Secret Wars
would be like with a bunch of different versions
just going crazy on screen.
I literally just did a video for that.
I know a lot of you've also started asking
why is Marvel recasting Kang but not Black Panther?
So in Marvel's own words, the producers
that were actually responsible for making that decision
a couple of years ago when they were getting ready
to make Black Panther, what kind of forever said that
because of the circumstances behind Chadwick
Boseman's passing at the time that they were doing
all this, making these decisions,
it felt inappropriate to just recast him
and pretend like nothing had happened.
Like just go with the original story
they had intended for in Black Panther.
Wakanda forever.
they said at the time what they wanted to do is
they wanted to change the movie to address his passing,
both in real life and in universal, which is why
they had his funeral at the beginning of that movie.
they eventually wanted to replace him with his son
T'Challa Jr once he came of age.
No idea when that's going to happen,
but that was basically their move
instead of just straight up recasting him,
give him a son, name him T'Challa
so that in however many years
you have T'Challa, Black Panther,
it just happens to be his son,
played by a totally different actor.
No matter what they do going forward,
Marvel is going to be in a really tight space.
It'll be interesting
to see how they try to get themselves out of this one.
Whatever they wind up
announcing, whatever winds up happening,
of course I'll do videos for it, so no worries.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
We have the Echo episodes coming next week.
Then we're going to get X-Men 97 episodes really soon.
Cannot wait to see what they did with their new X-Men
episodes.
Everyone click here for my
What If Season two Episode 9 finale video.
It does kind of go full Secret Wars
and click here for that new Daredevil and Echo trailer.
Thank you so much for watching
Happy New Year everyone,
and I'll see you in the next one!